خلال 20 عاما الماضيه تخرج من المختبرات
ابحاث طبيه دراسات جديده تقربنا من عالم
بلا امراض ورغم ان بعضها لم يتعدى التجارب
على الحيوانات الا انها لا تخلو من الامل
بنتائجها الايجابيه منذ عام 2003 توصل
العلماء الى مشروع جينا وما البشري ثبات
مفتاحا لفهم اكبر للجينات وتاثيرها على
الصحه والمرض وفي مجال مكافحه مرض السرطان
توصل العلماء للقاح ضد فيروس البابيلو مع
البشري الذي يسبب سرطان الرحم ليعتبر اول
لقاح للوقايه من المال لتتوالى بعضها
الانجازات بزراعه وجه كامل ثم نقل الاعضاء
والتوصل السريع للقاحات وصولا الى اجراء
العمليات عن بعد باستخدام روبوتات
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من هيو البروفيسور فيليب سالم
رئيس مركز سالم للامارات السرطانيه
وبروفيسور سالم من اهم الاطباء المتخصصين
في علاج السرطان في العالم ونحن نتشرف
باصطفاء باستضافته في عيد العربيه العشرين
بروفيسور يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا في
العربيه
يا اهلا فيك طيب عشرون سنه من الطب
البروفيسور وحضرتك من اشهر اطباء السرطان
في العالم خلال 20 سنه الماضيه ما ابرز ما
تحقق في مجال السرطان في هذا الاطار
انه انا
صار لي 55 سنه
بعالج الامراض السرطانيه
لذلك شفت التطور من بدايته الى اليوم
بالعشرين سنه
حيكون التطور سريع جدا
اسرع بكتير من تطور المعرفي اللي كان باخر
باخر عشرين سنه
سيحصل في
ثلاث مجالات المجال الاول
مثل ما بتعرفي انه الامراض السرطانيه في
ثلاث طرق
للمعالجه بالادنيه في العلاج المناعي
العلاج المستهدف
والعلاج التقليدي الكيميائي
التطور الكبير حيصير بالعلاج المناعي
والعلاج المستهدف ومع الوقت
حيخف دور العلاج الكيميائي
وسيكبر دور العلاج المناعي والعلاج
المستهدف هلا العلاج الكيميائي
النهور لما احنا نعطي دواء كيميائي
هالدواء ما بيفرق بين الخليه السرطانيه
والخليه الصحيحه
يقتل الخليه السرطانيه ويضر الخليه
الصحيحه لذلك في اعراض جانبيه كبيره
بالعلاج الكيميائي التقليدي
العلاج المستهدف هو لمن نعطي دواء
يستهدف فقط الخليه السرطانيه ولا يمس
الخليه الصحيحه باي ضرر
والعلاج المناعي
لا يستهدف الخليه السرطانيه مباشره
ولكنه يستهدف جهاز المناعه عند المريض انت
ايضا لست بالطبيب المختص فقط بل كاتب
واديب والكل يقرا مقالاتك الطبيه المتعلقه
بالطب في احدى مقالاتك عن ونت السرطان
يتنازل عن عرشه امام كورونا البعض اعتبر
ان هذا الطرح فيه نوع من المبالغه باعتبار
بان كورونا وكانها اصبحت موسميه غيمه
سحابه صيف وزالت ومن ثم هذا المرض الخبيث
الذي لا نعرف من حيث ياتي والى اين
هل المقاله اللي كتبته في
الشرق الاوسط
قلت انه تنازل عن عرشه على اساس مرحليه
وشددت على انه الكورونا هي مشكله مرحليه
سنه اثنين ثلاثه اربعه
وبزور بتزور هالمشكله مساله انه السرطان
سيبقى
معضله كبيره
لذلك تنازل عن عرشه سرطان بهالمرحله فقط
مستنازل بشكل دائم الموضوع
وبرجع احكي عن التقدم اللي حيحصل نحن
اليوم
صار عندنا العلاج المناعي والعلاج
المستهدف اللي قدموا تطور كبير بمعالجه
الامراض
وهالتطور حيكبر بالمستقبل
بهالمجلين هذا العلاج المناعي والعلاج
المستهدف
السبب وانه اليوم بالماضي كنا نعالج
المريض على اساس مصدر
مصدر المرض يعني هل هو سرطان ثدي ام سرطان
كولون ام سرطان معدي ام سرطان رئه اليوم
وبالمستقبل بالعشرين سنه القادمه
سيصير اهم من المصدر هو الهويه البيولوجيه
للمرض يعني شو مميز المميزات البيولوجيه
للمرض وبناء على المميزات نعطي الدواء
تيشل الخليه السرطانيه
ثلث الامراض السرطانيه تقريبا
هي نتيجه التهابات
جرثوميه اذا رحنا طورنا بالعشرين سنه
القادمه وانا متاكد انه حتطور على
اللقاحات
وتمنع الالتهابات الجرطبيه حيخف
حيخف نسبه الاصابات بالثلث وهذه بده يكون
مرحله جديده من
الوقايه من منصه
عندما تتحدثون وتصرون على الامل في معالجه
السرطان وهذا ما نتمناه جميعا اين يكمن
الامل تحديدا لجهه التقنيات كما تركزون
على العلاج المناعي كيف سيتم العلاج
المناعي لكل مشاهدي لو تبسطون
نحن اليوم
وصلنا الى درجه انه لما نمزج العلاج
المناعي مع العلاج المستهدف مع العلاج
التقليدي الكيميائي نحصل على نتائج كتير
افضل من النتائج اللي بنحصل عليها
بالعلاجات التقليديه وهناك فكره انه
السرطان لا يشفى منه
وهالفكره هي خاطئه جدا لانه نحن اليوم مش
عم نحكي بعد 20 سنه قادرين انه نشفي ستين
بالمئه من جميع مرضى السرطان ففسر فيلم
بما انه احنا بنحكي عن عشرين سنه وفي عيد
العربيه العشرين لماذا قلت يوما ما بان
المعرفه العلميه المعمول بها والتي يفترض
انها طبعا في خدمه البشر هي جزء صغير من
المعرفه العلميه التي نمتلكها من الابحاث
العلميه كيف
هذه نقطه كثير مهمه انه نحن المعرفه اللي
عنا اياها بالنظريه
منعا ما نستعمل على الارض ليه لانه هناك
عوائق كبيره تمنع اعطاء المريض افضل علاج
هل شو هي هل العقبات اول عقبه هو
التامين
لانه اذا انا بوصف علاج معين متطور مثل
اللي حكينا عنه المزيج العلاج المناعي مع
العلاج المستهدف مع العلاج الكيميائي
التامين شركات التامين ما بتدفع الكلفه
لذلك يضطر الطبيب انه يستعمل علاج تدفع
شركات التامين الكلفي تبعينه شركات
التمنيه التامينه عصبي باعطاء المريض افضل
علاج
تاني شيء هناك
[موسيقى]
الحكومات في العالم العربي وفي العالم كله
طريقه تامين الدواء الى المريض
هلا في بكون مريض عنده
امكانيه انه يشفى شفاء تام ولك بتطلعي
الدواء منو موجود او الدواء غالي جدا ما
بيقدر يامنه المريض
وما عنده انشورنس
في ثالث عقبه انه المريض مرت كتير من
السرطان ما بيروحوا الى اماكن متقدمه
للعلاج
بيروحوا الى عيادات
ما عنده هالبرامج
المتقدمه لمعالجه هذه الامراض
لذلك انت بتشوفي انه نحن بالرغم من انه
بنقدر انه نشفي 60% من المرضى بس بالحالات
العاديه على الارض نحن منعنشفي اكثر من
عشرين بالميه من المرضى ليه
السبب مش المعرفه السبب انه منع نقدر نحط
المعرفه بتصرف المريض
شكرا جزيلا لك على وجودك معنا في العربيه
العشرين من يستن البروفيسور
سالم لعلاج الامراض السرطانيه شرفتنا
ونورتنا بروفيسور شكرا جزيلا لك